Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary and in the
divine will of God and in the same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires and may you my beloved divine will
do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so
intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure and that
I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive even a breath of
resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints,
especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and
infuse in me true light so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. Well, as Amilda told you, our first message tonight is that our blessed mother
is the greatest model of living in the divine will. So we want to take April the 28th 1926.
Okay. So Louisa said, I was thinking to myself, when my sweet Jesus speaks of his will, he often
unites with it the sovereign queen of heaven and or creation. So either blessed mother or creation
or both and he's going to explain both in this particular message. So while I was thinking of
this, my beloved Jesus moved in my interior. Now that's Luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians 3 16.
At all tenderness, the text says he squeezed me to himself. I think in our country, we would say
he hoped me. My daughter, he said, if I do speak like this, I've strong reasons for it.
You must know that only in creation and in my celestial mother has my will remained ever intact.
That means neither creation nor our blessed mother ever shifted from the divine will.
That's what he means by remaining intact. And the divine will has kept its field of action
free, which it can only do if the person doesn't shift. So in the few messages I'll manage to do
tonight, you're going to hear him say over and over again, stay in your place. Don't move.
Just don't move. Give God a chance to work. Therefore, having to call you to live in my will
as one of them, that is either creation or blessed mother, as someone who would keep the divine will
intact and that they wouldn't move out of their place. So since I had to call you to be one of them,
I had to propose them to you as examples as an image for you to actually imitate.
So in order to be able to do great things in such a way that all may perceive that good
unless they don't want to, the first thing is that my will must act wholly in the soul. That means
that the divine will has to be able to operate in all of our soul completely. This is your
Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10 all over again, that you will love the Lord your God with all your heart,
with all your soul, with all your mind and with all of your being, not 99% of it.
So he's looking for people who will let the divine will operate 100%,
but it's 100% 100% of the time, not 100% now and then you take time out. That's not it.
So the first example he gives us then is creation in the next paragraph and then in the following
paragraph he's going to give us the example of our blessed mother. Why? Because creation came first.
So I want you to get you to look at creation and how my will is whole in it. That means that no
part of creation actually partitions the divine will. The plants don't say, well, give us the spring
off, we'll cooperate in summer. They don't do that. The divine will is completely whole
and the plant will do exactly what the divine will intended it to do.
And so with all of the galaxies and the stars and absolutely everything.
Now because the divine will is whole, creation remains always in its place. Now he's laying down
this principle for us. This is something we find difficult because as human beings we like change,
we like variety. We don't like being in the same place doing the same thing all the time.
We just don't like it. So creation remains always in its place and it contains the
fullness of that good with which it was created. Now of course he's going to give us an example
of the sun. He always does. So this is why because it remains in the same place, because it doesn't
shift even remotely from the divine will, it remains always new, noble, pure, fresh.
Now that's what he's looking for from us. That spiritually we will always be new,
noble, pure and fresh and can share the good that it possesses with everyone.
Now if the divine will is like that inside of us, it will be very, very easy to share with other
people because it will literally flow out of you. Just as the light flows out of the sun
and the rain flows out of the clouds and the plants lift up from the earth in their response
to God. But the beautiful thing is that while it gives itself to all, that is whatever piece of
creation we're talking about, it loses nothing and remains always the same just as it was created by
God. For example, what has the sun lost in giving so much light and heat to the earth? This lost
nothing. What of the Asia heavens lost by remaining extended in the atmosphere? Or what is the earth
lost by producing so much incredible variety of plants? This lost nothing. And so on with
everything else that was created. Oh, in what an admirable way does creation sing that wonderful
saying about me, he is ever old and ever new. Now the only person I can remember that that is
attributed to is Saint Augustine. Oh God, so ancient and so new, how late have I loved thee.
But if you go back into the scriptures, you will find that the prophets spoke about the ancient of
days. I'll come back to that later. It's one of the earliest things that was ever said about God,
he's the ancient of days. So no matter how far back in history you go, he is ancient, but he's ever
new. And this is a mystery that he wants to allow to begin to manifest in us that no matter how old
we are, that we are new today, completely new, fresh and pure and noble and that everything that
he wants to give to others can actually flow through us to them. So that reminds me, I think
it's Sam 90 that even though you are old, that you would be like the palm tree still full of sap
and still green even into old age, I think it's Sam 90. It's not just Sam 91. So it's ever old and
ever new. So we have to become like God ever old and ever new. So my will in creation is the center
of life. It is the fullness of good. And it is the order and harmony of the universe. So I now
remember that the ancient of days is the prophet Daniel chapter seven, verses nine and 13, just to
give you one example. The divine will keeps all things in the place wanted by it. Now here we have
the principle he's laying down for each one of us. Can you stay in the place? I don't mean the
physical place, but can you stay in the place that God appointed for you? Can you stay in the
vocation God gave to you? Can you persevere in doing God's will? If he gave you a task to do,
can you continue to do it right up into old age and right up to your death? Can you stay in your
place? Can you allow the divine will to operate in you more and more and more as time goes on
instead of less and less? So the more this reality is a lived reality in us, the more glory we give to
God. So the divine will is the center of life in creation. It's the fullness of good. It is the
order that you find in creation. It's the harmony you find there. The divine will keeps all things
in the place wanted by it. So where can you find a more beautiful example, a more perfect image
of living in the divine will, if not in creation? We just have to look around us.
This is why I call you to live in the midst of created things as their sister. Now remember
St. Francis of Assisi, brother, sun and sister moon. He understood this that we were to
relate to everything in creation as our brothers and sisters because the divine will is working in
us and in them. That you may learn to live in the supreme volition and that you may remain in the
place wanted by me. Now I've said that a good few times already and we're only just started.
That you will remain in the place wanted by me. Now how do we get out of the place
that he wants us to be in? It's by inserting our human will. That I want to do something
regardless of what God wants. That's how we mess things up. So that you may remain in the
place wanted by me to be able to enclose within yourself the fullness of the good that my will
wants to enclose in you. Now notice it's only as we remain faithful in the place that God has given
to us and with the grace that God has given to us that he can bring everything to perfection in us.
So that whoever wants it may actually take that good. So if Louis lives this to the fullness as the
one who opens the door to the divine will well the rest of us can go in and we can take as much
as we want. Just as when Jesus worked redemption for us we can go into his wonderful gift of redemption
and take as much as we want. That's why in the book of Revelation you meet saints, great and small.
We're not all the same size but as a priest I said to a group of us probably nearly 40 years ago
but I've always remembered it. He said don't ever envy anybody else the grace they have received
because spiritually if you're size 10 you get a size 10 cross and a size 10 crown a size 20 crown
wouldn't fit you and a size 20 cross would destroy you. But if you're size 20 spiritually
then the crown and the cross which is fitting for that size is right for you. So we must never
ever look to see what God is doing in other people to look with envy. What he is doing for you in you
is perfect for you. And so Jesus goes on and since you are endowed with reason you must surpass
them all. Now them all he's talking about creation. You must be better than the trees in standing there
for hundreds of years which lifting your leafy arms to pray and standing there in snow and wind
and rain and absolutely everything else but your remain standing. You've got to surpass them all
in fidelity, in greatness, everything. So we've got to surpass the sun, moon and stars as well.
It's amazing and you must requite your creator in love and glory for each created thing
as if they were endowed with reason. Now if you go to Sam 19 in some books it'll be Sam 18
verses 1 to 6 you'll be told that while creation is mute its message goes all over the world
everybody can see the glory of creation and unless they're completely dead they're inspired
to give thanks to God. Well we're being told that we are to be the speaking creation
that will put words on the glory that all of the rest of creation is giving to God that we have
to speak it out for them. We have to be their voice. So you will be the substitute for all creation
and creation will be a mirror for you. Now notice a teacher and guide
in which you can reflect yourself in order to copy the living in my will
so that you may not move from your place. Now if you are using your own book will you number
the number of times in this text already that the Lord has said he doesn't want us to shift from
where he has placed us that you may not move from your place in the divine will. The divine will
will be your guide and your teacher giving you the highest and most perfect lessons about living
in the divine will. We've got to stay in our place stay in a position of sacrificing our human
will to the divine and stay in the position of being open to let the divine will teach us.
Now that's our entry into the next paragraph where we get the second example and that's the
example of our blessed mother who surpasses everything. Okay so but the one who surpasses everything
in creation and all human beings and everything is my celestial mother.
She is the new heaven. So I want to give you two Corinthians 5 17 where the Lord said through Paul
that he wanted to create each one of us a new creation and that new creation happens in the divine
will. So she was the new heaven she was the most refulgent sun the brightest moon the most
flowery earth she encloses everything everything he said within herself that's difficult for us to
just imagine this that she was so great. If each created thing encloses the fullness of its
own good received by God my mother encloses all goods together because since she is endowed with
reason and my will lived wholly completely perfectly permanently in her the fullness of grace
light and sanctity grew in every instant. So here you have her having sacrificed her own will
from the very dawn of her creation and so there is 100% openness to the divine will
continuously every second of her life and therefore the fullness of grace and light and sanctity and
everything grew at every second. Now we can have very stunted growth because we go off on our own
tracks. Jesus said every act that she did was suns and stars that my will formed in her in other
words everything was a completely new creation every single act is absolutely amazing.
So every act she did was suns and stars that my will formed in her so she surpassed the whole
of creation and my will whole and permanent. Now there's another word added to all that we've had
already in this text permanent. Not only did she stand her ground and remain completely open
but it was for every single moment of her existence the divine will was safe inside of her she was
not going to shift and so my will whole and permanent in her did the greatest thing now watch this
carefully and impotrated the longed for Redeemer. Now in other messages that we have read
a very clear impression was given that she was the one who impotrated the long for Redeemer and she did
but since she was completely and totally given to the divine will Jesus says that it was the divine
will in her that did this praying that did this intercession and that's what the Lord wants for us
as well that we will reach a point where the divine will praise according to his own will inside of
us and one of the ways you'll know you're moving in that direction is that your prayer will be
continuously universal that it will embrace the whole of creation it will embrace everybody
nobody will be left out so the universal prayer is one of the signs so the divine will in her
impotrated the longed for Redeemer so this is why my mother is queen in the midst of creation
because she surpassed everything and my will found in her the nourishment of her reason now
notice he has emphasized before that Louisa is different from the rest of creation because she
has reason and she has free will and blessed mother also has free will and she has her reason so it is
a reasonable sacrifice it is well thought out it's not something on the spur of the moment it's not
just an impulse of reaction this is her whole intellect surrendered to God her intellect memory
and will completely surrender to God so my will found in her the nourishment of her reason
which made the divine will live as whole and prominent in her therefore she fulfilled due to
her anime 6 4 to 10 there was the highest accord they held each other's hands that means in total
union and there was not one fiber of her heart or word or thought over which my will did not possess
its life so now you look at what is meant by being fully and completely and totally and wholly in the
divine will there was not one fiber of her heart so that includes the desires and the motivations
there was not one word or thought the words are the result of thoughts there was nothing inside of
her that opposed the divine will in any way and what kind of divine will not do it can do
everything because God is omnipotent there's no power that the divine will lacks and there's nothing
it can't do how often you meet that in the scriptures particularly when people are really being challenged
our blessed mother herself was told at the enunciation that nothing is impossible with God and if we
would remember more often that nothing is impossible with God we'd have an awful lot less problems
therefore it can be said that my mother did everything because the divine will was completely
free to act and everything that all others together could not do nor will be able to do
she did all by herself now I love that expression she did all by herself and when I was thinking
about that the thing that came clearly into my mind it was that beautiful poem by William Wordsworth
on the virgin in which he said that she is our tainted nature's solitary boast it's a wonderful
piece absolutely wonderful so some people have tried to to put words on it so having told us that
blessed mother did everything by herself covered everything that God wanted covered in the divine
will in the next paragraph he tells us that the greatest thing left to the divine will is to try
and get the rest of us to come around if you can get the rest of humanity and when I was reading this
I had an image that came to me whether it is totally accurate or not I couldn't tell you but
you know when a baby is being born the head comes first and then all the bulk of the body comes
afterwards and that can be slower and more painful and all the rest of it if you think of a train
you have the engine room first and then you have all the wobbly carriages afterwards and if you're
going to have a disaster it'll be the wobbly carriages usually and so it was easy enough for the Lord
to get this accomplished in and through our blessed mother because of the perfection of our being
but when he comes to very imperfect people like us then he has a problem he got to really work hard
therefore he says do not be surprised if I point out to you the creation and the sovereign queen
as models okay because I must point out to you the most perfect examples in which my will has
perennial life so it's permanent it's not going to go away as perennial life and my will has never
found an obstacle to its field of divine action notice the word never and notice how many messages
we've read long before we got to volume 19 on the disaster of the human will because we blocked the
Lord but in creation and most particularly in our blessed mother the divine will was completely
free to act as he is in heaven and he's going to try and do that on the earth itself my daughter
if you want my supreme fiat to reign on earth as it does in heaven which is the greatest thing
that's left for us to do in the human generations let my will have the place of sovereign in you
so he's saying this to Louisa as the number one but then we're all trotting after her where the
little army of souls trying to live in the divine will so this is not being spoken to Louisa
as I read it it's being spoken to you and me that the Lord is saying let my will be sovereign
in you as an individual and stop worrying about all the people around you and all your relatives
and all your neighbors and all the rest let it happen in you when our blessed mother let it
happen in her all redemption followed and so if we let it happen in us what God wants to do
in our generation will happen so let the divine will be sovereign in you and let it live as whole
and permanent there is the challenge do not be concerned about anything else
you need to really take this on board these few lines I think need to be written in green white
and gold do not be concerned about anything else be it your own incapacity or the circumstances
you're living in or the new things which may surprise you all around you why are you not to be
concerned this is incredibly important today in the midst of this fake pandemic that we're in
and all the things that are happening all around us he says why are you not to be concerned it's
because my will reigns in you that's why we're not to be concerned and if we continue to let
the divine will be sovereign in us and live as whole and permanent then all these other new things
that are happening all around us and are disturbing everybody else they will serve as raw material
and as nourishment so that my fear my habits fulfillment God can use anything now when I read
that the thing I think about is a good cook who can take bits and pieces from kitchen covered and
make a most beautiful meal so long as you wouldn't ask me to do it you'd get a disaster but if you
have a decent cook they can do it think of what a an artist can do with little bits and pieces that
the rest of us will throw out it's because they have this gift well the lord is telling us that
no matter what disasters are happening around us worldwide today he could use everything absolutely
everything so long as we let the divine will remain whole and entire in us now notice how much depends
on us so there is a said that afterwards she was thinking to herself it's true that the queen mother
made the greatest of sacrifices which no one else has made that is sacrificing her will at the very
first instant of her being that is not even wanting to know her own will but only that of God and
through this she embraced all sorrows all pains up to the heroism of sacrifice now notice up to
because the lord is going to tell her in the next paragraph that her reasoning here isn't right
okay so watch this you can be a saint and you can be wrong this is something very important
we must not presume that if somebody is holy they've got everything right that it's not true
so so here she's saying yeah blessed mother had all pains up to the heroism of sacrifice
sacrificing her own son so there i want to give you genesis 18 Abraham ready to sacrifice his own
son and i want to give you two Samuel chapters 1 and 2 Hannah who sacrificed her son not in death
by handing him over to the temple and to the high priest and he became Samuel one of the
greatest of the prophets so up to the heroism of sacrifice sacrificing her own son in order to do
the supreme will but once she made this sacrifice everything she suffered afterwards was the effect
of her first act now louisa here is reasoning according to teaching we've already done that God
has one act and everything comes out of that so louisa is now saying that everything came out of
that one first act of our blessed mother giving herself in the first moment of our being nor did
she have to struggle as we do this is very interesting because this is the way we would reason and
i think that's why it's put here it's the way we think and then the lord's going to say no no no
it's not like that at all so she didn't have to struggle so there's also having a little bit of
self pity we have all this struggle and she didn't have it and we're in different circumstances in
unforeseen encounters and unexpected losses it's a constant struggle to the point of making our
hearts bleed for fear that we might surrender our own belligerent human wills now that's us talking
and louisa is actually expressing it very well how much attention one must have so that the supreme
will may always keep its place of honor and its supremacy over everything and many times this
struggle is harsher than the pain itself so just louisa giving our way of thinking very well okay so
what's the lord thing so while i was thinking this she said my beloved jesus moved in my interior and
he said to her you are wrong why that's brilliant you are wrong the mactimum sacrifice of my mother
was not only one but there were so great and so many that's why i said if you're size 20 you get a
size 20 cross and the size 20 crown will fit you now by comparison with blessed mother i don't
actually have a measurement at all don't know about you and he said the mactimum sacrifice of my
mother was not only one but there were so great and there were so many for as many as were the sorrows
the pains the circumstances and the encounters to which her existence and mine were exposed in other
words they carried a very heavy cross she before he was born bolted them afterwards pains were always
doubled in her because my pains were hers i even more than her own besides this is very important
besides my wisdom did not change direction with my mother in other words the lord didn't change
his ways with her as he deals with everybody else in each pain that she was to receive i always asked
her whether she wanted to accept it now go back over particularly the first nine or ten volumes
of louisa and you hear jesus asking her all the time will you do this will you suffer this will
you cooperate with the other and he's asking her cooperation all the time so why is he doing that
and why does he keep saying to us you know you should keep using yourself all the time you should
keep doing it watch this now in each pain she was to receive i always asked her whether she wanted
to accept it in order to hear that fiat being repeated to me in each pain in each circumstance
and even in each heartbeat of hers people who are new to divine will will say to you
i put it in the pavilion act in the morning it doesn't that cover everything and the point is
it would yes if you stayed in that position for every single second of your being
under the following morning but we're not like that and so we have to fuse all the time
offer each pain no matter how small it is offer each challenge no matter how small it is
in the divine will he wants us to do this all the time that fiat resounded so sweet and gentle
and harmonious to me he said that i wanted to hear it being repeated every instant of our life
now she's our model and he was enjoying hearing this wonderful incredible surrender of his mother
in our case she's our model we're not at her level not by the longest imagination you could have
but that we're being reminded to keep coming back keep coming back keep coming back keep coming back
keep fusing keep offering keep coming back keep doing it and eventually someday there may be a
very very deep deep deep surrender in us that we thought we might have given before but now it's
actually given and so each offering leads us to a deeper and deeper and deeper commitment to the
divine will so this is why i would always ask her mother do you want to do this do you want to
suffer this pain and my fiat would bring her the seas of the goods that it contains
so she would know what it contained just as louisa did as well and would make her understand the
intensity of the pain she was accepting this understanding through divine light as is exactly
the same as louisa louisa says so frequently a divine light came to me and i understood
we call that divine light infused knowledge so this understanding through divine light of that
which step by step she was to suffer gave her such martyrdom as to infinitely he uses the word
infinitely surpassed the struggle which creatures suffer in other words it was divine pain now
in the last few volumes we have come to understand that louisa was brought to the level of suffering
divine pain as well as she tells you it's completely unbearable it can bring about death if she wasn't
supported in fact jesus said about his mother that since the seed of sin was missing in her
the seed of struggle was also missing because that seed of struggle comes from our rebellious will
it comes from the fall and she didn't have that and so my will had to find another device
that she might not be inferior to other creatures in suffering because having to inquire by justice
the right of being the queen of sorrows she had to surpass and suffering all creatures put together
now you go back over that first paragraph in which louisa was doing very human thinking
they kind of stop the we do and jesus says no you have it all wrong you've got to come at this from
a completely different angle and i think that in itself is a wonderful revelation that while a
person can be very holy and very committed to god they can be wrong and their thinking can be
wrong on something so i i don't know about you but i find that very consoling and so we go on
so jesus said to louisa how many times have you yourself not experienced this
that while you felt no struggle within you as my will would make you understand the pains
it inflicted upon you now this is a reality more and more as you get up into the higher volumes
not so much in the lower volumes where everything had to be negotiated
so the divine will also made louisa understand the pain that she was going to suffer and you would
remain petrified by the intensity of the pain he said and while you were undone in that pain
now i understand that a small little bit it leaves you paralyzed she can do nothing she's
petrified as she describes it herself you were the tiny little lamb in my arms ready to accept yet
more pains to which my will would want you to be submitted so what he's saying here is that he had
brought louisa to this point where she was beyond struggle now because the whole struggle was dealt
with in the early volumes and she has reached a very very deep union with the divine will
and so there isn't a struggle but she can be literally petrified petrified is a very strong word
because if you look at wood that is petrified you're going to get no movement out of that
so it is a an almost death experience from pain and he describes that when she's in that condition
she's like a lamb in his arms and she would take more if she could but she can't watch this
the struggle is a sign of vehement that is intense passions while my will if it brings
suffering gives intrepidness is what my book says is that what the word that she was there
and that means fearless makes you fearless it makes you daring in your relationship with god and
you often hear louisa saying excuse my daring makes you bold it makes you courageous you know
now notice he says vehement passions really he's talking about self will
and self will can be we we've all witnessed people digging the heels in
we've all witnessed people shutting down and that's it no more communication
and that's what he's talking about vehement passions that something in us
absolutely closes up and says no those far and no further whereas in the divine will
while the suffering given to you might be quite intense or very intense the lord gives you
the courage of a hero or a heroine as well and so the grace corresponds to the cross that's actually
given so the struggle is a sign of intense passions or self will while my will if it brings suffering
brings you fearless courage and with the knowledge of the intensity of the pain
it gives one such merit that only a divine will can give so there you're being brought up to
the level of divine pain and merit therefore just as i act with you that in everything i want from
you first i ask you whether you want it whether you would accept it i did the same thing with my mother
in other words you must give your fear and don't forget in the things that happen in your daily life
that cross your will don't forget to say to the lord not my will but dine be done not my will not
my will not my will but dine be done we've got to absolutely make that a mantra
and you have to do this so that the sacrifice may be always new with a new fiat every time
and it may give me the opportunity to converse with the creature to be able to be with her
and my volition may have the field of divine action in the human will let me put that slightly
differently the lord doesn't want us to give him stale bread i said fiat a couple of months ago
i said fiat the other day today i'm having a day off a stale bread he wants the new fiat
the new gift all the time so now louisa said as i was writing what was written above i could not
continue on because my mind was estranged from my senses by a beautiful and harmonious chant
as she's listening to the angels accompanied by a sound never heard before this chant called the
attention of everyone and harmonized with the whole of creation and with the celestial fatherland
i write this only to obey as i was hearing that chant jesus told me my daughter hear how beautiful
it is this sound and this chant is a new canticle formed by the angels as homage glory and honor to
the union of the divine will with your human will now for those of you who are doing the book of
revelation with me i want to remind you of the new hymn of redemption in chapter seven
chapter five of the book of revelation the hymn of moses and the lamb in a chapter 15 just to
give you two examples it's always new it's always new it's always new and the lord wants fresh bread
from us every single time as well so since louisa was the first of ordinary folks who had been born
in the ordinary way with original sin to come to this level the angels actually create a new hymn
of praise and glory to god it's beautiful so the joy of all heaven and of all creation is so great
that unable to contain it they play and they sing i think it's lovely after he said this he said i
found myself inside of myself so let's come to me that first and we're talking about ruach adonai
that is the breath of god very beautiful uh trying to finish this one i felt all immersed in the
supreme volition louisa said and my sweet jesus came out from within my interior and hugging me
tightly to himself he placed his mouth close to my lips and set me his omnipotent breath now if you
go to john chapter 20 verse 22 you'll find that after the resurrection jesus did that with the
twelve apostles receive the holy spirit ruach adonai but who can say what i felt within me she said
the breath penetrated deep into my innermost fibers it filled me completely to the point that i no
longer felt my littleness my existence but only jesus within all of me Galatians 220 i no longer live
christ lives in me or john 14 verses 20 to 21 you and me and i and you completely won then after
repeating several times this act of sending me his breath as it seemed he was not content if he did
not see me completely filled with that divine breath he told me my daughter since you are born
in my will it is necessary it is right it's proper that you live and grow and be nourished in the
divine will now notice it's not enough to enter you've got to actually live in it you've got to grow
deeper and deeper and deeper in the divine will we have to nourish ourselves in the divine will
and you have to acquire the prerogatives of a true daughter of my volition and blessed mother is the
model no extraneous feature nor anything which does not belong to my will must appear in you
so here we're at the stage now nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of god so
the demands made on the person at this particular level are actually very deep
stuff that you would have allowed yourself off with years ago completely off now therefore
from your outward appearance from your your way of doing things your manners from your speaking
and even from the way you love and pray it must be seen by others and recognize that your daughter
of my will whoops so here he's saying you have to get to the point where somebody actually looking
at you would know that you were actually a very special being now they mightn't be able to use
the words in the divine will do you see then how i love you and what i jealousy i keep you and nourish
you with my very breath because only my breath can preserve whole and prominent the life of my
will in one who must live in my volition only the holy spirit can do it this is the holy spirit age
the third fiat is the reign of the holy spirit upon the earth okay and each one of us must be
filled with the spirit that's why i think that the charismatic renewal that broke out in the church
at the same time as the Vatican council was a preparation for the divine will it was when
people were introduced to the holy spirit introduced to repenting of their past introduced to feeding
on the scriptures feeding on prayer feeding on adoration of the eucharist and growing in holiness
all of that was preparation and it fits volume one so as far as i'm concerned the definitive moment
when the holy spirit descends upon the earth is the new pentecost the fulfillment of Joel chapter
three yet the holy spirit would fall upon all flesh and jesus says and so that breath which
with so much love i released from my bosom in the creation of man to infuse in him my likeness
we can only be like god if we have the breath of god within us just genesis two seven i continue
to infuse in the soul who lives in my will in order to form my true images that's Romans 8 29
so there's no way we can live in the divine will without an infusion of the holy spirit
there's no way we can persevere in this way of life without the holy spirit literally being our
teacher and guide so i continue to infuse in the soul who lives in my will in order to form my true
images and the great portents which i had established to form in creation for which all things were made
so this is why i long so much for one who lives in my will because she alone will not leave me
disappointed in the purpose of creation she alone will enjoy by right the things created by me
because since my will is one with hers what is hers is mine and what is mine is hers and by right
she can say the heavens the sun the earth and all things are mine and the amazing thing is that if
you say that it doesn't affect anybody else's enjoyment of the sun or the light or the earth or
anything else therefore i want to enjoy them also to give honor to that supreme will which created
them and which reigns in me so on the other hand the soul in whom my will does not reign has no right
we've had this message given to us a number of times has no right and if she enjoys them she's a
usurper because they do not belong to her she's an intruder in my goods because my goodness is great
and therefore i let her enjoy them as ambs but not by right this is why many times the elements
unload themselves over man to his harm this is nature at war with man when man is at war with the
divine will so we can expect huge events in the near future because the human race is in rebellion
against god in a huge way at the moment so the elements will unload themselves over man to his
harm because he has no right and what is left for him of the things of the earth are the ambs that
the creator sends to him in other words we are not experiencing the wonder of creation as we should
be nor the fruits nor the healing power is nothing but one who lives in my will is like a queen in
the midst of creation and i greatly delight in seeing her reign in the midst of the goods so
in the next paragraph the lord is going to talk about what i call the circle of the divine will
and what i mean by the circle of the divine will is it comes down to us from heaven but it has come
to go back from us to heaven to have that circle completion so louisa said after this i continued
to pray and my sweet Jesus came back making himself seen with two fountains of light now this is the
divine will coming out of his hands one of them descended over my poor soul and through a device
which was formed in his hands while descending it went up again so you remember the angels of god
ascending and descending the ladder jacobs ladder mentioned in john 151 it seemed to be a continuous
current she said which while descending ascended jesus was all delighted in the midst of these
fountains of light and was all attentive so that one of them would remain all centralized in me
because the divine will was centralized in her then he said to me my daughter this fountain of light
which descends from my hands is my will which descends from heaven and makes its way into the soul
in order to accomplish what it wants to do within her so the divine will comes to us to try
and accomplish what his plans are for us this action of my will forms the other fountain of light
which through my hands ascends again because jesus said he was the fulfillment of jacobs ladder
so through my hands ascends again towards heaven to bring the fulfillment of my will from the creature
to the eternal creator but while ascending at the same time it descends again doubled
to continue its divine action in the creature so you've got this continuous motion it never
ever stops that's why he's been talking about the divine will being whole and permanent in us
peraneal in us is the word he uses so it never stops if the motion of the divine will could be
stopped which cannot be life would cease for the whole of creation life would cease for the stone
for the starry heavens for the plants for the water for the fire for the creatures everything
would be reduced to nothing it would be the end therefore with its continuous motion my will is
the life of each created thing it binds everything it is more than air which with its breath makes
all things which come out of our hands breathe develop and vegetate now i want to give you john
151 i want to give you jennises 28 verses 10 to 17 and i want to give you sam 85 verses 10 to 13
and i won't let you look them up yourself because time is over but i want to do the next paragraph
with you see then what in a front is given by creatures because while my will is the life of
everything and the center of all things and without it nothing and no good would exist they do not
want to recognize its dominion nor its life which flows within them this is why one who recognises
the life of my will within herself and in all things is the triumph of our will and the conquest
of our victories i need to underline that because this is where we're at trying to be in this position
this is why one who recognises the life of my will within herself and recognises in all things
the triumph of our will that is in creation and the conquest of our victories she is the recompense
of our love to our continuous motion our will binds this creature to the whole of creation
making her do all the good that my will itself does now he has to enable that to happen we can't do
it by ourselves we can do nothing by ourselves john 15 5 without me you can do nothing but Philippians
4 13 with him i can do all things in christ so everything is hers and i love her so much that
i am unable to do anything without her because by virtue of my will we have the same life we have
the same love we have one single heartbeat and one single breath that's what you call union with god
i want to give you one Corinthian 6 17 we become one spirit with him
and while he was saying this he threw himself into my arms as though faint with love that's
song of songs chapter 4 verses 9 to 10 and what the lord is saying here is that those of us who
live in the divine will were actually living the life of the blessed in heaven on earth and the
difference is their suffering is over and we must carry our cross to the end of our testimony
so i leave it there for tonight thank you for coming and loie lephoric for honor give we should
the best for saint patrick's day